the
I think right now everybody is already
perceiving that this is the decade of AI
and there is nothing like artificial
intelligence that drives the
digitization of the world historically
artificial intelligence has always been
the pioneer battalion of computer
science so when something was new and
untested it was done in the field of AI
because it was seen as something that
requires intelligence and found a new
way of modeling things intelligence can
be understood to a very large degree is
the ability to model new systems to
model new problems and so it's natural
that even narrow AI is about making
models of the world for instance our
current generation of deep learning
systems are already modeling things
they're not modeling things quite in the
same way with the same power as human
minds can do it they're mostly
classifiers not simulators of complete
worlds but they're slowly getting there
and by making these models we are of
course digitizing things we are making
things accessible and data domains we
are making these model accessible to
each other via computers and via AI
systems and AI systems provide
extensions to our minds already now
Google is something like my XO cortex
that's something that allows me to
access vast resources of information
that get integrated in the way I think
and extent my abilities if I forget how
to use a certain command in a
programming language it's there at my
fingertips and I entirely rely on this
like every other programmer on this
planet this was something that this
incredibly powerful and it was not
possible and we started how to
programming then we had to store
everything in our own brains
I think consciousness is a very
difficult concept to understand because
we mostly know it by a reference you can
point at it but it's very hard for us to
understand what it actually is and I
think at this point the best model that
I've come up is what what we mean by
consciousness it is a model of a model
of a model that is our new cortex makes
a model of our interactions is the
environment and part of our neocortex
makes a model of our of that model that
is it tries to find out how we interact
with the environment so we can take this
in
to account when you interact with the
environment and then we have a model of
this model of our model which means we
have something that represents the
features of that model and we call this
the self and the self is integrated with
something like an attentional protocol
so we have a model of the things that we
attended to the things that we became
aware of well the process things that
might be interacted with the environment
and this protocol this memory of what we
attend the tour's would be typically
associated with consciousness so in some
sense you are not conscious and
actuality in the here-and-now because
that's not really possible for a process
that needs to do many things over time
in order to retrieve items from memory
and process them and do something with
them consciousness is actually a memory
it's a construct that is we invent in
our brain several times a minute and
then we think about being conscious of
something it means that we have a model
of that thing that you can that makes it
interoperable that we can use you're not
really aware of what the world is like
the world out there is some via quantum
graph it's something that we cannot
possibly really understand first of all
because needs observers cannot really
measure it we don't have access to the
full bit vector of the universe what we
get access to is the few bits that our
sensors can measure in the environment
and from these bits our brain tries to
derive a function that allows us to
predict the next observable bits so in
some sense all these concepts that we
have in our mind all these experiences
that we have sounds people ideas and so
on are not features of the world are
there there are no sounds in the world
out there new colors and so on these are
all features of our mental
representations they are used to predict
the next set of bits that are going to
hit our retina or eardrums I think the
main reason why I was started was that
it was designed to understand the mind
it was meant to take over where it
psychology stop making progress
sometime after Piaget at this point in
the 1950s psychology was in the thrall
of behaviorism that means that it only
focused on observable behavior and in
some sense psychology has not fully
recovered from this even now thinking is
not really a term in psychology and we
don't have good ways to study thoughts
and mental processes what we study is
human behavior in psychology and in your
science the mostly study brains your
nervous systems my entire something
similar a different there are in between
there are what brains do and there are
the reason for our behavior and this
means there is some information
processing that is facilitated by brains
and that serves to produce particular
kinds of behavior and this information
processing can be studied the designs of
information processing which happens to
be computer science so AI was by no
accident started as a subfield of
computer science but one of its major
interests was always when the
understanding of what minds are what we
are what our relationship to the
universe and I think you can argue that
along the way AI has lost its focus
because there were more obvious benefits
with automation was much easier to make
progress and many of the paradigms that
needed to be understood and invented
they're not available in the first
decades of the field right at the
beginning of the field of artificial
intelligence people ask themselves how
do we recognize that a system is
intelligent and often in this context we
think about the Turing test the idea of
the Turing test is that you build a
computer that can convince its audience
that it's intelligent but when you look
for intelligence we actually look for
something else we are looking for
systems that are performing and Turing
test on us what that means is that the
system checks what we are conscious of
it's what we do with each other all the
time we try to find out what does the
other person think whether the other
person understand which parts of the
world does this person have
consciousness of what part of this of
the world is this person able to model
and when we will have built an AI that
is truly intelligent it will probably
recognize it intelligence and of a by
the thing asking us and checking whether
we are intelligent and conscious or the
same things that is a understand by
itself that's because the system is able
to understand that itself is the mind
that is conscious of certain things and
all of others and the same must be true
for it into the quarters I do think that
when we build a system that is able to
implement the same functionality as our
brain and has to perform similar tasks
that it would have similar consciousness
to ours and practice that's rarely going
to be the case the a is that we are
going to build in the future are
probably not going to be humanoid robots
for the most parts it's going to be
intelligent systems so a eyes are not
going to be something that lives next to
us like household robot or something
that then tries to get uman rights and
throw off the joke of its oppression
it's a household slave or something
instead it's going to be for instance
corporations nation state and so on that
are going to use for the intelligent
task machine learning and computer
models that are more more intricate and
self modeling and become aware of what
they are doing so we are going to live
inside of these intelligent systems not
next to them you're going to have a
relationship to them that's similar to
the gut flora has to our organism and to
our mind you're going to be a small part
of it in some sense so it's very hard to
map this to a human experience because
the environment that these AIS are going
to interact this is going to be very
different from ours also I don't think
that these AIS will be conscious of
things in the same sense as we are
because you're only conscious of things
that require our attention and you are
only aware of the things that you cannot
do automatically most of the things that
we do don't require our attention most
of the simple stuff in our body is
regulated this feedback loops and most
of the other stuff is just going on by
itself because we haven't trained our
brain with useful routines to deal with
them and only when there is a conflict
between these routines then we become
aware then something gets our attention
and Prestage experiencing it integrating
it in our protocol and I think there's
an argument to be made that even as we
build human-like intelligence if that is
just perfecting that it might become so
good at its task that it's really going
to be conscious of what it's doing
because it can you do all automatically
you
[Music]